[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
si le danger que représentait l'affaire
de Cuba s'est éloignée il n'en est pas
moins nette que la mission de Monsieur
tante secrétaire général de l'ONU s'est
réduite à des entretiens plutôt qu'à un
contrôle effectif du démantèlement des
bases de missiles soviétique sur ces
entrefêtes un voyage surprise à La
Havane Vigan New York de Monsieur
mikoyam ou le second de Monsieur projov
et de nature à consolider l'impression
de détente monsieur mikoyann avait
semble-t-il pour mission de calmer
Castro mécontent et en même temps
d'apaiser les Américains
fidèle à la tradition comme elle célèbre
la Grande-Bretagne avait sorti ce jour
là le carrosse royal la couronne et
quelques chapeaux melons la reine et le
prince Philippe se dirigeaient vers le
Parlement avec tout l'apparence dans
lequel l'ouverture de la session
annuelle ne serait pas ce qu'elle est
cette année cependant les chevaux de la
reine ont introduit à la fois de
l'inédit et du suspense dans ce cortège
réputé classique
on a pu croire un instinct qu'ils
allaient refuser à la souveraine
l'entrée du Parlement on n'avait jamais
vu ça
si l'on ajoute à cette manifestation de
non-alignement le refus tout net de
participation opposées par l'un des
chevaux à son cavalier une question se
pose faudra-t-il désormais composer
jusque dans les écuries royales avec
l'opposition de Sa Majesté
[Musique]
nul aujourd'hui ne sont à prendre la
route sans assurance le fait-il qu'on ne
manquerait pas chemin faisant de le lui
rappeler
pensez aussi en vous engageant sur les
routes de la vie que le BCG est à sa
manière une assurance sur la vie mieux
une assurance de vie c'est ce que la
nouvelle campagne contre la tuberculose
entend vous rappeler
le professeur Bernard l'a officiellement
ouverte en remettant au directeur
général de la santé publique le timbre
qui donnera de nouvelles armes contre ce
fléau hélas encore vivaces mais
vis-à-vis duquel on peut toujours se
prémunir efficacement
[Musique]
le verdict de Liège met toutes les
consciences en allais voici quelques
mois la police belge annonçait cinq
arrestations la prison Saint-Léonard
s'ouvrait pour une femme Madame Van
deputte son mari sa mère et sa sœur plus
le docteur casters sous l'accusation
d'avoir tué un enfant né difforme
dans la maison des vannes de [ __ ] on
s'était pourtant réjouis de la naissance
prochaine
[Musique]
mais la future maman du prendre un
tranquillisant le docteur caster lui
conseilla le softéno se produit
considéré comme le véritable responsable
du drame le bébé naquit anormal
alors avec l'assistance du docteur
caster la famille Van de [ __ ] cru de
voir supprimer l'enfant pour lui
épargner une vie de douleur et les
pouvoirs publics devant ce cadre
dramatique interdire le médicament à qui
dit-on l'on doit à travers le monde
7254 naissances d'anormaux
7254 dB n'est monstrueux comment
concevoir un drame aussi pathétique
aussi le procès de Liège ce procède
l'euthanasie intéressent-ils toutes les
consciences
c'est pourquoi les assises de Liège ont
attiré une assistance record le dossier
du softeno a drainé venu du monde entier
plus de 150 journalistes et reportés
les accusés emprisonnés depuis cinq mois
ont pris place dans leur boxe encadrés
de gendarmes
les malheureux parents accusés
d'assassinat la mère et la soeur de
Madame Van deputte enfin le docteur
caster
mais est-ce bien un assassinat que la
loi doit juger et c'est là le problème
le père et la mère étaient-ils en droit
de prendre une telle décision le docteur
casters et la mère de Madame van
desputte dit consentir et d'y prêter la
main les jurés ont bien plus qu'une
cause à juger car c'est dans toute son
ampleur le problème le plus dramatique
de la conscience humaine
[Musique]
la mort de Madame Gabriel Flammarion que
les astronomes du monde entier avaient
surnommé la compagne des étoiles n'a
sans doute pas eu dans le public un
grand retentissement elle ramène
toutefois l'attention sur un nom
aujourd'hui familier dans le jardin de
l'Observatoire de Juvisy ou repose son
mari et où chaque année à l'anniversaire
de sa mort elle conduisait le cortège de
ses fidèles amis elle reposera à son
tour à l'ombre de cette maison où elle
fut la compagne et la collaboratrice du
grand homme
c'est là en effet qu'en 1883 Camille
Flammarion fonda cette observatoire où
il devait jusqu'à sa mort survenue en
1925 accomplir l’œuvre immense de
savants et de vulgarisateur de génie qui
mit l'astronomie à la portée de tout le
monde tout ce temps Gabriel Flammarion
ne fut pas que la compagne de tous les
jours
elle collabora à ses travaux nombreux et
divers qui devaient assurer la célébrité
de son mari après sa mort elle continue
à une œuvre qui a peut-on dire ouvert
les arcanes du ciel aux écoliers
tout depuis 1925 est resté comme la
laisser Camif la Marion
dans cet ancien relais de poste ou
Napoléon a pris en 1814 l'entrée des
alliés à Paris tout rappelle encore
cette vie de recherche ici où est né en
partie le roman de l'astronautique
sachez aujourd'hui un chapitre de la
grande encyclopédie des sciences
[Musique]
l'arrivée de deux premiers minéraliers
de 32000 tonnes dans le nouveau bassin
du port de Dunkerque va nous obliger à
réviser nos cours de géographie le plus
puissant ensemble sidérurgique français
se trouve aujourd'hui implanté au bord
de la mer c'est l'aboutissement d'une
conquête des sables entreprises en 1960
500 hectares ont été ici gagnés à
l'industrie lourde
[Musique]
amener d'outre-mer au pied même de
l'usine sidérurgique édifiée à l'abri
d'une digue de 7 km le minerai passe
presque sans interruption au parc de
stockage et de la au fourneaux
[Musique]
deux fourneaux ultra moderne et de
grande capacités la Syrie trois fois la
superficie de Saint-Pierre de Rome
permettra à uzinor de produire dans un
an un million 500 mille tonnes d'acier
d'ores et déjà les premières tôles
fortes ont été laminées c'est tôle forte
dont l'industrie française devait
jusqu'ici apporter un tonnage important
Dunkerque une nouvelle capitale de
l'industrie lourde
la technique assez passionnée ainsi
s'explique que chaque jour tout un
peuple dont l'âge varie de 10 à 70 ans
se presse au Palais de la Découverte à
Paris pour regarder passer des trains
il faut dire que le spectacle en vaut la
peine sur 40 mètres quelques 150
locomotives et 800 wagons modèle réduit
évoluent à travers un décor si
minutieusement fidèle à la réalité que
l'illusion est parfaite
un aimable chef de gare présidents
complexes des 14 trains qui circulent
ensemble
[Musique]
quels sont les prestiges de la technique
il y aura toujours des foules pour
s'émerveiller devant sa perfection même
en réduction
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
décidément les footballeurs français
n'ont guère de suite dans les idées
ainsi les Rémois en maillot foncé
soumettent leur supporter au système de
la douche écossaise très brillant devant
le Stade Français quelques jours plus
tôt ici face au niçois il reçoit une
leçon d'opportunisme et d'efficacité
[Applaudissements]
anis les joueurs ne s'embarrassent guère
de fioritures ils utilisent les longues
ouvertures en avant
regardez cette phase de jeu
[Applaudissements]
tout cela c'est moi classique mais là
vraiment les défenseurs Rémois ont l'air
de Pantin maladroit
et le second puni Swan n'est pas volé le
mois du monde
les choses ne vont pas il n'y a plus
qu'à baisser les bras c'est à peu près
ce que font les rémois qui ont rarement
aussi mal joué et comme les Niçois eux
jouent bien c'est un troisième but que
va encaisser un
[Applaudissements]
il s'agissait certes d'un accident pour
les Rémois mais elle avait de leur match
de Coupe d'Europe contre l'Austria de
Vienne c'est tout de même un peu
inquiétant montant de l'addition 4 0
la France va voter devant les mairies
les panneaux et les affiches réaniment
aux yeux des électeurs un décor
désormais classique avant la
confrontation politique le général de
Gaulle avait tiré les conclusions du
référendum
la loi constitutionnelle
telle qu'elle a été votée fait que
dorénavant le peuple français et l'Iran
son président au suffrage universel
ainsi
devra demeurer
cet élément capital
de permanence et de solidité que
comporte nos institutions je veux dire
la présence au sommet de la République
d'une terre qui puisse en être une
mais
voici quand votre temps oui la nation
vient de dégager une large majorité de
rénovation politique
je dis
qu'il est tout à fait nécessaire
pour que dure la démocratie
que cette majorité s'affermit et sa
grandissent et d'abord qu'elle s'établit
son parlement
[Musique]
en ce jour du 11 novembre le général de
Gaulle accompagné du Premier ministre
est allé s'incliner sur la tombe de
l'inconnu qui représente pour les
Français le centre même de la patrie le
lien essentiel le symbole de leur unité
devant tous les périls et tous les
problèmes
[Musique]
celle qui fut la compagne attentive du
président Franklin Roosevelt s'est
éteinte à l'âge de 70 ans
compagne attentive elle l'avait été
durant les 12 ans où elle fut la
première dame des États-Unis après la
mort du président elle avait poursuivi
une intense action sociale et culturelle
à travers le monde
fidèle à la mémoire de son mari c'est
elle qui accueillait les autres
illustres venus s'incliner sur la tombe
du président
[Musique]
c'est un rythme de plusieurs milliers
par jour que ce succès de les
engagements dans l'armée indienne pour
répondre à l'agression chinoise qui
commençait voici quelques semaines
semble prendre de jour en jour plus
d'important on parle en effet de 13
divisions chinoise massées au Tibet et
prête à intervenir
[Musique]
des manifestations anti chinois se
succèdent à New Delhi où tout ce qui de
près ou de loin est susceptible de se
rattacher à Pékin et sévèrement traité
que des magasins ou des entreprises
connues comme de dépendance chinoises
ont été saccagées et leurs enseignes
brûlées en dépit des anciennes
déclarations de Monsieur Nero l'histoire
prend-elle un nouveau tournant en Asie
manifestation violente à Pékin c'est
foule auxquelles le portrait de Castro
sert de riflam manifeste au sujet de
l'affaire de Cuba ces mouvements
populaires sont paraît-il spontanés mais
on peut quand même en douter devant la
quantité de panneaux Castries de modal
identiques qui défilent devant
l'ambassade de Cuba
use que vivait le monde semble n'avoir
pas atteint Pékin dont l'opinion ainsi
manifester confirme le désaccord latin
avec Moscou mais l'étalage d'un tel
esprit n'est pas pour le monde entier
d'un heureux Augus
les pluies torrentielles qui sont tombés
4 jours durant sur la Catalogne et ont
fait craindre le pire dans une région
que les inondations avaient déjà éprouvé
un mois plus tôt à Barcelone à sa Babel
à Taraba on a dû multiplier les
évacuations devant les proportions que
prenait la crue des rivières
[Musique]
route coupée cité privée de gaz et
d'électricité 4100 abris c'est de
nouveau le triste lot de la catalogue
[Musique]
à Liège la foule qui s'était rassemblée
devant le palais de justice dans
l'attente du verdict était comme
l'expression de l'intérêt passionné qui
a soulevé dans le monde le procès qu'il
faut bien appeler le procès du softéno
les 12 jurés n'ont pas voulu punir
Suzanne et Jean vanne de [ __ ] ni madame
Kappel la grand-mère de la petite
Corinne qui n'avait pas pu se résoudre à
laisser vivre une enfant non monstre ils
n'ont même pas voulu juger leur acte en
répondant non à la première question ils
l'ont volontairement ignoré
c'est la fin d'une durée preuve pour
tous et libre la soeur de Madame Van
deputte la mère le père la grand-mère se
sont abandonnés à la satisfaction de la
foule comme Madame caster s'en retrouve
en son mari comme le docteur caster
praticien dont tous les témoignages sont
venus confirmer les qualités morales le
verdict de Liège un verdict qui a
préféré l'humanité
[Musique]
et footballeurs français ont manqué leur
rendez-vous avec les spectateurs
parisiens qui étaient venus au stade de
Colombes pour les voir gagner devant les
Hongrois ils ont été vite rafraîchis par
la pluie d'abord et par le premier but
en bois
cependant les Français Mayo légèrement
plus clair que leurs adversaires n'ont
pas baissé les bras
regardez le numéro 10 vous le reverrez
souvent dans l'équipe de France voilà il
marque son but comme un il se nomme
dynalo il a 19 ans et il a dû tout payer
comme une grande vedette qu'il sera
peut-être bien tôt grâce à lui tout
n'est pas perdu
[Applaudissements]
mais Léon droit eux aussi savent jouer
au football et mieux que dynalo
résultats 2 buts à un pour les Hongrois
le sang pour le son dynalo ne va pas
s'arrêter en si bon chemin et d'ailleurs
il était né par toute l'équipe de France
qui de temps à autre montre de bien
belles facettes de santal
me revoilà le petit allô rien ne la
pressionne lorsqu'il s'agit d'aller
marquer un but
c'est comme cela que l'on devient le
chouchou des spectatrices vous vous
rendez compte deux buts à lui tout seul
il ne reste pendant pas été logique que
le match fut perdu par les Hongrois qui
finalement ramène la France à la réalité
en gagnant par trois à deux
cet avion français c'est un futur
champion du monde lorsqu'il aura terminé
ses essais dans un an il sera l'avion à
réaction le plus rapide de sa catégorie
en attendant pour le moment c'est une
espèce de gros frelon qui décolle
verticalement et qui atterrit de la même
façon il peut même faire du surplace
dans le ciel c'est déjà un record mais
lorsqu'il sera définitivement au point
après le décollage ils bondira comme une
fusée à deux fois la vitesse du son le
nom de ce futur champion des airs le
Balzac
les sportives et les jolies femmes n'ont
pas du tout le même langage le mot forme
n'a pas pour elle la même signification
Bob hop en ce qui le concerne a l'air de
préférer le vocabulaire des jolies
filles
la championne des États-Unis a des
performances à faire valoir
[Musique]
elles ont toutes des arguments
convaincants pour conquérir le titre de
Miss Monde et si vous n'aimez pas
celle-là vous en choisirez une autre
[Musique]
la championne s'est Miss Hollande elle a
gagné d'une courte poitrine sur Miss
valand et sur Miss France bien que
n'étant pas championne de course à pied
elles seront sûrement faire courir les
hommes c'est là que les sportives et la
jolie femme ont un point commun
[Musique]
en déposant à la mairie de
Colombey-les-Deux-Églises sont bulletins
dans l'urne
pour la accompli son devoir si vite
comme 28 millions de Français appelés à
élire une nouvelle assemblée
en déposant elle aussi son bulletin dans
l'urne de la troisième circonscription
de la Seine mademoiselle limonton
employait banque a usé du même pouvoir
ainsi du plus célèbre au moins connu des
électeurs chacun a fait son choix parmi
les options politiques proposées à tous
les Français
le problème posé par la dissolution de
l'ancienne assemblée a pu sa mort remuer
l'esprit public quelle figure en effet
les élections donneront-elles à la
future rassemblée par rapport à
l'ancienne
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
d'une première journée de scrutin on ne
peut tirer que des conclusions
partielles au ministère de l'Intérieur à
la fin du scrutin on décomptait 96 élus
et un glissement de voies considérable
se révèle le ministre monsieur Roger
Frey pouvait constater à l'issue de ce
premier tour la confirmation du succès
des oui
[Musique]
la crise qui avait provoqué
l'installation de base de fusées
soviétiques à Cuba approche de son
règlement l'opération de réembarquement
des pièces à conviction autrement dit
des missiles soviétiques a été accomplie
comme prévu les avions de surveillance
américain ont contrôlé leur présence sur
le pont des navires en route pour l'URSS
et évaluer leur nombre 42 transportés
par 8 bâtiments
cependant les marines qui ont la garde
de la base américaine de Guantanamo à
Cuba n'en continue pas moins de
perfectionner leur système défensif sur
les crêtes des collines environnantes il
double leur défense de trancher de
barbelés et de parapet Fidel Castro
continue en effet de réclamer
l'évacuation de la base et ses soldats
ont établi leur position non loin des
positions américaines les Américains
sont sur leur garde mais les risques de
conflits sont de moins en moins probable
[Musique]
en Inde pendant que la guerre continue à
la frontière chinoise les femmes
tricotent pour les combattants
et monsieur nérou qui célèbre son 73e
anniversaire a pu constater qu'il ne
manquait pas de bonne citoyennes pour
faire également le sacrifice de leur
bijoux
or et argent ainsi réunis contribueront
à accroître le potentiel militaire d'un
pays pour lequel jusqu'ici neutralisme
et pacifisme avait été la règle formelle
[Musique]
celui qui donna de la Parisienne une
image si particulière que cette
silhouette a pris son nom le peintre
Jean-Gabriel Domergue est mort il avait
73 ans
il avait décédé du triompher dans les
portraits féminins pour lesquels il a
inventé un style élégant et des envoltes
qui lui attira très rapidement de grands
succès monde il n'aura sans doute été
que le peintre de cette Parisienne
longue et effilée qui marque à notre
époque mais l'époque avait adopté cette
vision de la Parisienne et le nom de
Jean-Gabriel Domergue restera
inséparable de cet élégante silhouette
ce n'est certes pas la première fois que
le Corbusier expose à Paris on a donc
revu le célèbre architecte et urbaniste
à qui l'on doit une grande part de la
renaissance de l'architecture moderne et
dont les œuvres maîtressent jalonnent
les grandes villes du monde entier des
Indes au Brésil cette exposition n'est
cependant pas comme les autres car Le
Corbusier il montre deux aspects de son
talent la peinture et la sculpture que
sont gémir architectonique avait laissé
dans l'eau
[Musique]
chez drouen les goncours André Billy
Roland orgelès Gérard Bauer Philippe
Heriat et leur si complice ont accompli
leur double tâche traditionnelle ouvrir
la saison des prix et consacrer un
nouveau talent par la voix de Philippe
heria ils ont cette fois voué à la
gloire et son corollaire le gros tirage
une romancière dont les bagages de sable
sont le deuxième roman Anna lancrus
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette année encore la fondation de
l'avocation créée et animée avec un
dévouement inlassable par Monsieur bleu
Stein Blanchet a fait 26 heureux à
chacun de ces 26 lauréats garçons et
filles échoua avec leur diplôme un joli
chèque de 10000 nouveaux francs qui leur
permettra de suivre l'appel de leur
vocation combien d'autres fautes d'un
peu d'argent non plus suivre la voie qui
les appelait et c'est ainsi qu'entre une
future aviatrice et un futur violoniste
on a vu le jeune Pierre Thomas se
réjouir de devenir un jour dompteur une
bonne action une belle action
[Musique]
un immense chantier au-dessus du sol à
l'entrée de Paris ici c'est d'ici l'un
des plus vastes réservoirs d'eau du
monde la capitale française n'a cessé de
s'accroître et bien entendu du même coup
se sont accrues ses besoins en eau
potable c'est au nécessité de demain
qu'on a songé en dotant Paris d'un
nouveau réservoir d'une capacité de
200000 mètres cubes sa construction est
entièrement réalisée en béton précontre
ce procédé accroît la solidité du
matériau et permet à résistance égale
d'utiliser des éléments plus légers
[Musique]
ce réservoir sera en réalité composée de
deux cuves distinctes édifiées côte à
côte on remarquera la forme alvéolaire
des parois qui le rassure une plus
grande résistance au pression
[Musique]
à noter ici que les piliers n'ont pas
qu'une simple tâche de soutien il
contribueront aussi à briser la
turbulence de l'eau à l'intérieur du
réservoir
quelques semaines encore et toute cette
construction aura disparu sous un tapis
de gazon il ne restera plus ici pour
l'oeil qu'un jardin public
[Musique]
et je meurs de Reims maillot blanc
culotte noir ont toujours eu à faible
pour la Coupe d'Europe depuis sa
création ils ont joué deux fois la
finale cette année encore ils espèrent
participer à la finale mais pas pour
rien ils veulent gagner la Coupe
d'Europe s'il joue tout leur match comme
ils l'ont fait devant Austria tous les
espoirs leur sont permis voyez plutôt
même papa s'amuse maintenant à marquer
des buts
les Rémois ont réalisé un match très
brillant très prometteur pour l'avenir
je pétillant esprit d'équipe bref un
véritable festival oui mais voilà le
public a tout gâché un public trop
partiel et trop fanatique
les Rémois n'avaient pourtant pas besoin
de cette alliance délirante des
spectateurs pour gagner le match à
présent un quart d'heure de jeu déjà 2 à
et comme ce n'est pas suffisant que pas
en tête numéro 9 les Rémois continuent
de jongler avec leurs adversaires et de
marquer les buts
voilà qui est fait 3-0
pourquoi donc le public a-t-il cru de
voir en rajouter par ses explosions de
cris et d'injures envers les joueurs de
skrilla déjà forme Harry de recevoir une
leçon de football vraiment il ne
méritait pas cela
d'autant qui s'y Copa leur donne le coup
de grâce 4 à 0 un coup de grâce que
parachève a15bi 5-0
et copain le héros d'un très grand match
est rassuré pour l'avenir de son club
[Applaudissements]
ce n'est pas encore demain que la France
retrouvera un titre de champion d'Europe
des poids moyen avec hippolytanex les
derniers espoirs des spectateurs du
Palais des Sports à Paris se sont
évanouis après moins d'une demi-heure de
combat en montant sur le ring annexe
était persuadé qu'il deviendrait
champion d'Europe en triomphant du
hongrois lâche l'OPAC annexe c'est le
plus grand des deux boxeurs celui qui
porte des choses sur blanc
après un premier round assez difficile
le boxeur français très en progrès a
donné l'impression qu'il n'avait pas
peur d'être ambitieux mais dès le
quatrième round annexe et handicapé il a
touché à l'arcade sourcilière il ne voit
plus que d'un œil et comme lâche le pape
n'est pas aveugle le Français n'a plus
qu'à craindre le pire
le pire se produit au 9e rang
[Applaudissements]
et oui ça fait mal un crochet du droit
qui fait mouche annexe et le sera pas
champion d'Europe
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nationale va de nouveau retrouver son
animation le résultat des élections
telles qu'il est apparu dans la nuit du
dépouillement sur les tableaux du
ministère de l'Intérieur a donné à
l'hémicycle une physionomie toute
différente de celle d'hier
[Musique]
le ministre de l'Intérieur monsieur
Roger Frey pouvait annoncer que l'un NR
est disposerait avec la pointe des élus
sous l'étiquette de la Cinquième
République de la majorité absolue
situation qui ne s'était pas produite
depuis 1919
comme une liste et socialiste gagne des
sièges grâce au désistement par contre
les indépendants perds de les deux tiers
de leurs élus et le MRP le tien
une fois installé cette nouvelle
Assemblée doit soutenir l'action
nationale de redressement poursuivi par
le général de Gaulle
[Musique]
un homme de cœur tel a été la première
image du président Coty conduit les
Français au soir de son élection à la
magistrature suprême dans les affaires
publiques il fut un arbitre à la fois
respecté et affable averti et tolérant
[Musique]
sa vie de chef d'État devait être
traversé par un deuil cruel la mort de
Madame Coty le laissait seul face aux
exigences de l'Élysée en venant
nombreuses devant l'église de la
Madeleine la foule parisienne avait
partagé sa douleur
[Musique]
puis la France s'était retrouvée en 1958
en plein drame et le président Coty
avait pris la décision d'appeler celui
qui pouvait le résoudre et laissait
alors selon ses propres paroles le
premier des Français être le premier en
France
[Applaudissements]
le président Coty s'était retiré au
Havre sa ville natale
les Havré qu'il avait alors accueilli
avec chaleur le pleure aujourd'hui comme
tous les Français
[Musique]
personnage familier le payeur des
allocations familiales traduit l'aide à
portée à chaque foyer pour élever ses
enfants derrière ce geste banal pour la
région parisienne comme partout en
France il y a l'immeuble de la caisse à
l'intérieur le spectacle d'une
administration des temps modernes ces
machines permettent la ponctualité des
paiements et des économies de frais de
gestion on se trouve à présent dans tous
les départements d'une organisation qui
trouve sa justification dans l'immense
et fort de solidarité l'entreprise
depuis 15 ans on ne s'étonnera pas
qu'une telle administration vivent à
l'heure de l'électronique à partir d'un
fichier c'est la machine qui débute les
feuilles de paiement concernant 8
millions d'enfants
les sommes versées par les allocations
familiales représentent des
investissements dont aucune autre
entreprise n'atteint le chiffre
750 milliards d'anciens francs par an
sont en effet investis dans la jeunesse
la sidérurgie investit que 235 milliards
l'électricité de France 286
c'est dire l'importance des élections de
descente les chefs de famille vont
désigner les membres des conseils
d'administration chargés de la gestion
des fonds ainsi que de l'action sociale
en diminution depuis 1936 la population
française a fait à partir de 46 des bons
prodigieux près de 43 millions à 54 les
Français viennent d'atteindre le chiffre
de 47 millions et faites qu'on n'est pas
imaginer il y a 20 ans la France est
devenue aujourd'hui le pays le plus
jeune d'Europe
les moins de 20 ans représentent
aujourd'hui près du tiers de la
population totale
grâce à quoi dans 20 ans la population
active atteindra le chiffre record de 30
millions
il ne fait pas de doute que les
investissements réalisés jusqu'ici par
les allocations familiales ont permis
aux familles d'élver une jeunesse saine
et active les producteurs de demain
[Musique]
c'est dire que de telles investissements
sont rentables toute la jeunesse qui
grandit qui remplit les écoles
d'aujourd'hui c'est le gage pour demain
de la promotion d'un pays
[Musique]
pour les chemins de fer français 1962
sera la grande année de
l'électrification après Paris Dunkerque
et Paris Marseille l'attraction
électrique à mistrasbourg à 4h30
seulement de Paris et la plus grande
région industrielle du pays dispose
aujourd'hui d'un réseau électriqueié
très important pour faire face au trafic
dû à l'expansion industrielle du bassin
lorrain il a fallu aménager un nouveau
centre de triards ainsi est né le
chantier de Woippy créé de toutes pièces
de la gare de triage de Woippy aura
l'importance de Villeneuve-Saint-Georges
c'est-à-dire ce qui s'est fait de mieux
en France et de plus grands en Europe
5000 wagons pourront y être triés chaque
jour
sera doté des derniers perfectionnements
de la technique notamment en ce qui
concerne l'aiguillages automatique
demain on entreprendra la liaison Reims
Marseille les lignes électrifiées du
Nord et de l'Est apparaissent ainsi
comme les artères ou pas si l'on peut
dire le pou de l'Europe de demain
[Musique]
existe-t-il un péril singe pour le
village de minigami au Japon peut-être
c'est une histoire véridique il y a
quelques temps de cela les villageois
ont tout fait pour attirer dans leur
parc les charmants primates de la forêt
voisine ils y sont parvenus ceux qui
leur a valu depuis les visites très
régulières des touristes
[Musique]
seulement les singes se sont très vite
conduits comme un pays conquis on ne
compte plus leur facéties leur larcin
leur pillard
[Musique]
ils sont partout et la vie est devenue
impossible et pourtant l'inégamie ne se
résout pas à choisir conserver cette
attraction pour attirer les touristes ou
chasser les pillards
et si l'advient qu'un pauvre petit singe
se prenne dans les fils électriques et
s'électrocute voilà le secouriste de
service qui se précipite et tout est mis
en œuvre pour animer la victime
[Musique]
que le singe meurt et on lui fait un
service funèbre pour que les esprits de
sa tribu usent de leur influence pour
faire rester toute la troupe au village
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour le moment à mi-neigami les singes
demeure et le dilemme aussi
[Musique]
que peut-on faire à cette époque sur une
plage normande et surtout que justifie
un télaire de concentration
d'applications notre reporter en appui
tenir il a posé la question mes
camarades
donc
qu'est-ce que vous faites alors ils
viennent pas tout seul quand même là
après tout le monde ramasse en vrac
voyez-vous et puis pour être détaillé au
chantier quand les corbeilles sont
pleines ils montent ils chargent sur ces
espèces de couffins que vous voyez là de
chaque côté des chevaux
le mystère demeurait entier restait à
suivre les chevaux au couffin chargé de
galets au bout du chemin le mystère
était encore plus épais notre reporter
se trouvait à présent devant une
véritable petite usine
parc de stockage trieur électrique
et même calibrage méticuleux décalée les
plus précieuses en double mais après
vous savez s'est mis en sac ça venait
petit les petits sont mis enceinte et
les gros sont expédiés et par wagon vous
voyez parce qu'il y a encore autre chose
c'est qu'il faut faire attention de ne
pas les casser vous les chargez tous en
vrac ou tous en sac
parce que c'est sous le contrôle de
Grenier qui eut pensait que les cailloux
pourraient peser dans la balance
commerciale de la France
[Musique]
qui est riche en galet n'est-elle pas un
risque de concurrence pour vous non
jusqu'ici nous avons du beau et du bon
galet que font vos clients de ces galets
absolument rien
des galets ça sera mince avec respect ça
se vend mais on ne saura jamais à quoi
ça sert
[Musique]